quiero repasar lo que vimos en el vídeo
pasado y hacer un diagrama un poco más
grande porque me parece que en el vídeo
pasado todo terminó estando muy
amontonado sobre todo por aquí en este
diagrama y esto que vivimos por aquí es
un concepto súper importante
así es que quiero que quede muy claro
por lo que vamos a volver a hacer este
diagrama pero de tal forma que quede muy
claro que tenga mucho espacio y vamos a
explicar con un poco más de profundidad
algunos detalles que quedaron explicados
de una forma muy superficial así es que
nos vamos a regresar a este punto en el
que vamos a dibujar un pedazo de la
membrana de unt y la coi de dentro de un
cloroplasto lo que hoy vamos a dibujar
esta misma membrana de aquí pero ahora
por acá y la vamos a dibujar mucho más
grande aquí estamos dibujando a esa
membrana pero de una forma muy grande
así es que este es el interior del pti
la coidh y podemos imaginarnos que esta
membrana de agua
y se cierra y forma a un tila koi de de
este lado tenemos el lumen y la coidh al
lumen y afuera de la membrana por acá
tenemos el estroma que es el líquido que
llena a todo el cloroplasto el estroma y
ahora esta membrana es como cualquier
otra membrana de cualquier órgano lo
claro que está es una membrana que
además está adentro de un orgánulo pero
como es una membrana cualquiera es una
bicapa fosfolípidos y ahora estoy
mencionando esto acerca de la membrana
porque en este vídeo quiero que nos
preguntemos cómo le hacen los protones
para atravesar esta membrana ok quiero
que nos preguntemos cómo se le hace para
utilizar la energía de los electrones
para hacer que pasen los protones a
través de la membrana pero bueno como ya
sabemos todas las vigas fosfolípidos
tienen dos partes hidrofílicas al
exterior de la membrana y por supuesto
estas partes son hidrofílicas porque
trabajan muy bien en ambientes polares y
el interior de la membrana que tiene
esta forma de cadenas es no polar y por
lo tanto es hidrofóbico y bueno podría
dibujar el resto de la membrana de esta
forma pero me tardaría siglos ahora lo
que sí vamos a dibujar son los
componentes que vimos en el vídeo pasado
ok tenemos algunos complejos que se
encuentran a lo largo de toda la
membrana pero el complejo con el que
empezamos es el foto sistema 2 botó
sistema 2 y luego más adelante tenemos
el foco sistema 1 y también vamos a
dibujar el atp sin tasa por aquí que
también se encuentra a lo largo de la
membrana y tiene por aquí esta parte que
es como un motor y ya sabes pasan por
aquí protones de hidrógeno y hacen que
se mueva a esta parte del motor que
obliga a una molécula de adp ya un grupo
fosfato a juntarse y formar una molécula
de atp vamos a hablar un poco más de eso
en unos cuantos segundos
ahora antes quiero que repasemos el
hecho de que el primer lugar donde los
electrones se existen es en la clorofila
del fotosistema 2 aunque los electrones
excitan a un nivel más alto de energía y
conforme van pasando de complejo a
complejo van bajando su nivel de energía
hasta que llegan al fotosistema 1 donde
nuevamente vuelven a ser excitados a un
mayor nivel de energía y otra vez va
bajando su nivel de energía conforme van
pasando al siguiente complejo y todo
este tiempo esa energía que se va
perdiendo se utiliza para bombear
protones de hidrógeno a través de la
membrana ok para bombear protones de
hidrógeno del estroma al lumen pero
ahora la primera cosa que yo me
preguntaría de este diagrama es porque a
este de aquí le llamamos el fotosistema
2 y a este él fotosistema 1 cuando en
realidad estamos empezando desde aquí
bueno la razón es que este se descubrió
primero ok este foto sistema fue
descubierto primero aunque en las
reacciones de la fase luminosa haga su
trabajo después que el otro foto sistema
éste se llama foto sistema 1 porque fue
descubierto primero sin embargo es en el
foto sistema 2 donde empieza todo esto
ahora cada foto sistema tiene distintos
pares de clorofila en sus centros de
reacción por ejemplo en el foto sistema
2 tenemos a los pares p 680 y en el foto
sistema 1 tenemos a los pares p 700 y
estos números provienen de la longitud
de onda de la luz que mejor absorben las
clorofilas de cada foto sistema el 680
de aquí corresponde a 680 nanómetros que
es la longitud de onda que mejor absorbe
la clorofila del foto sistema 2
aquí y 700 se refiere a 700 nanómetros
que es la longitud de onda de la luz que
mejor absorben las clorofila de este
foto sistema en fin ahora lo que quiero
hacer es dibujar por aquí otro diagrama
para hablar acerca de los niveles de
energía de los electrones lo expliqué de
una forma demasiado superficial en el
vídeo pasado y quiero profundizar un
poquito más en el asunto en fin ahora lo
que quiero hacer es dibujar por aquí
otro diagrama para hablar acerca de los
niveles de energía de los electrones en
distintas moléculas así es que voy a
dibujar por aquí otro diagrama
y voy a escribir por aquí las distintas
moléculas de las cuales puede formar
parte del electrón por ejemplo el
electrón puede ser parte de h2o también
puede ser parte de la clorofila y
también puede ser parte de la fe oficina
y voy a hablar de esto un poco más
adelante p oficina estoy escribiendo por
aquí todas las moléculas de las cuales
puede formar parte el electrón así es
que también tenemos que escribir por
aquí al aplasto quignón a flash toki
nona y luego tenemos el complejo
citocromo v6 efe pero simplemente voy a
escribir b6 efe y luego también tenemos
el aplasto se anime pero simplemente
vamos a poner ps no necesariamente te
tienes que aprender estos nombres pero
bueno si estás estudiando fotosíntesis
puede ser útil ok por cierto aquí está
clorofila
se encuentra en el foto sistema 2
luego el electrón también puede estar en
la clorofila del fotosistema uno se
puede encontrar en la clorofila del
fotosistema 1 y luego también puede
formar parte de la fe robox ine pero
simplemente vamos a escribir una fp y
luego la verdad es que tenemos por aquí
otras moléculas que no vamos a escribir
hasta que llegamos a la sector final de
electrones llegamos al n
de p más que una vez que acepta el
electrón se convierte en n
dp h ahora en este diagrama arriba
significa que tenemos un alto nivel de
energía y más abajo significa que
tenemos un menor nivel de energía en el
electrón así es que empezamos por aquí
en el agua y los electrones están muy
cómodos en las moléculas de agua y en la
clorofila están incluso más cómodos o
bueno al menos esta es la forma en la
que yo lo veo así es que si lo dejamos
solito este electrón nunca se va a mover
de la cloro
y la a pero todos sabemos qué es lo que
sucede los fotones llegan recorriendo
una distancia de 93 millones de millas y
a los fotones los podemos ver como
pequeños paquetes de luz o como ondas de
luz pero de cualquier forma llegan los
fotones y excitan a algo en el foto
sistema 2 que no necesariamente tiene
que ser la clorofila
también puede excitar a alguna otra
clorofila antena u otros pigmentos y
después utilizando la energía de
resonancia los fotones vibran y llegan
hasta la clorofila a excitando a sus
electrones así es que este electrón de
aquí se excita y llega a un estado de
energía más alto aunque bueno cuando
llega a un estado alto de energía se va
directamente a la fe oficina que es el
primer aceptar de electrones
pero bueno regresando a la clorofila y
aquí abajo tenemos una imagen de la
clorofila a lo cree y así se ve la
clorofila
y como podemos observar aquí tiene una
cola de hidrocarburos esto de aquí es la
cola de hidrocarburos y por acá tenemos
la cabeza de una molécula que es el
anillo de por feeling a ok este grupo de
aquí se llama por fibrina por fina y
justo en el centro tiene unión de
magnesio ok esto de aquí es un guión de
magnesio y cuando los fotones llegan y
vibran por aquí o bueno cuando llega
hasta la clorofila a la energía de
resonancia proveniente de las moléculas
antena los electrones de los enlaces
dobles de este anillo de por fin se
excitan y esos electrones son de los que
hemos estado hablando todo este tiempo
así es que estos electrones se excitan y
su primer aceptar es esta fe oficina de
la que hemos estado hablando okay esta
fe oficina de aquí
que por cierto la fe oficina se ve muy
parecido a la clorofila
excepto porque no tiene este ión de
magnesio en el centro y bueno aquí
estamos viendo esto tal vez con
demasiado detalle pero el punto es que
la fe of it in esta estructura que
tenemos por aquí que es parte del photo
sistema 2 la fe oficina es el primer
sector de electrones así es que el
electrón excitado de la clorofila
salta a la fe oficina que no tiene este
guión de magnesio en el centro y cuando
se encuentra en la fe oficina tiene un
nivel muy pero muy muy muy alto de
energía tenemos aquí al electrón en un
nivel muy alto de energía pero sigue
moviéndose de molécula en molécula y
ahora pasa al aplasto quignón a ok
pasamos a un nivel de energía
ligeramente más bajo por aquí está
nuestro electrón ahora y vuelve a pasar
a un nivel un poco más bajo de energía
llegando al complejo citocromo v6
efe
y luego llegamos al aplasto ziani na
bajando un poquito más el nivel de
energía del electrón y finalmente
llegamos al fotosistema 1 con un nivel
de energía relativamente bajo aunque tal
vez ligeramente superior al nivel de
energía que teníamos cuando pensamos en
el photo sistema 2 en la clorofila
pero entonces llega a otro grupo de
fotones al fotosistema 1 y existen tal
vez algunas moléculas antena quienes a
través de la energía de resonancia
terminan excitando nuevamente a este
electrón aunque también puede ser que
los fotones lleguen directamente a la
clorofila de los centros de reacción del
foto sistema 1 y entonces nuevamente el
electrón se excita ok el electrón se
excita y nuevamente tenemos un electrón
con un alto potencial que conforme se va
moviendo de molécula en molecular va
bajando su nivel de energía hasta que
eventualmente se queda en una molécula n
h ahora aquí el electrón todavía tiene
bastante energía y aquí este electrón
todavía puede ser transferido a alguna
otra de estas moléculas y seguir con
esta cadena de transporte de electrones
y vamos a volver a hablar de eso cuando
estemos hablando de las reacciones
independientes de la luz y ahora durante
toda esta parte se estuvo liberando la
energía cuando el electrón pasaba a
niveles de energía más bajos y esa
energía que se libera se utiliza para
bombear protones de hidrógeno a través
de la membrana ahora eso sólo sucede en
esta parte de la cadena de transporte de
electrones en esta otra parte de la
cadena aunque también se libere energía
no se utiliza para bombear protones de
hidrógeno ahora la razón por la que yo
quería hacer este diagrama es para que
viéramos que el electrón empieza en un
nivel de energía bastante bajo
que todo lo que sucede por aquí sucede
gracias a la energía de la luz solar
esto definitivamente no puede suceder
por su cuenta no puede suceder sin ayuda
del exterior que un electrón pase a un
nivel de energía más alto por su cuenta
pero bueno en el vídeo pasado hablamos
de cómo este electrón se excita y va
pasando de molécula en molécula
liberando energía hasta llegar al foto
sistema 1 en donde vuelve a ser excitado
y nuevamente va pasando de molécula en
molécula hasta llegar a n además y
convertirlo en línea de ph ahora tú aquí
me puedes preguntar oye pero de dónde
salió la h de dónde salió el hidrógeno
pero bueno tenemos por ahí protones de
hidrógeno flotando entonces tal vez el
electrón llega al protón de hidrógeno y
se junta con n además y listo nos queda
ndp h ahora la otra pregunta muy
importante es qué es lo que va a
sustituir a este electrón de aquí y aquí
y es donde entra esa cosa impresionante
de la que estaba yo hablando en el vídeo
pasado aquí es donde se oxida el agua y
la oxidación es pérdida de electrones
así es que por aquí o bueno mejor dicho
por acá se oxida el agua en este lugar
de oxidación del agua del fotosistema 2
y entonces uno de los electrones del
agua se queda en la clorofila
para sustituir a este electrón que se
fue por acá y nuevamente repito eso de
poder llegar a oxidar al agua es algo
impresionante pero bueno hagamos otro
repaso de lo que sucede por aquí
básicamente lo que estamos haciendo es
utilizar la energía de la luz solar la
energía de los fotones para oxidar a las
moléculas de agua para quitarle sus
electrones a las moléculas de agua y
como ya sabemos los electrones en las
moléculas de agua casi siempre están
girando alrededor del oxígeno así es que
básicamente lo que estamos haciendo es
quitarle los electrones al oxígeno
elevar su nivel de energía muchísimo y
que finalmente el electrón termine en
una molécula de ndp h y a lo largo del
proceso en esta parte estamos bombeando
protones de hidrógeno a través de la
membrana los cuales como vimos en el
vídeo pasado debido a la quimio hemos is
vuelven a atravesar la membrana pasando
por el canal de la atp sin tasa lo cual
provoca que esta parte gire y así se
formen las moléculas de atp
ok cuando los protones pasan por aquí se
forman las moléculas de atp a partir de
moléculas de a de pepe y grupos fosfato
y ahora este proceso en el que pasan
protones de hidrógeno y se forman
moléculas de atp a partir de estos lo
veo con mucho detalle en el vídeo de la
cadena de transporte de electrones
cuando estoy hablando acerca de la
respiración celular y vemos de una forma
más visual
es que sucede esto otra pregunta muy
natural en este punto es cómo le hacemos
para bombear protones de hidrógeno a
través de la membrana y bueno aquí vamos
a hacer una explicación super
simplificada el proceso es mucho más
complejo pero podemos imaginarnos que
aquí en el foto sistema 2 tenemos por
acá a la fe oficina que tiene a este
electrón por aquí y repito esta es una
simplificación exagerada pero bueno
digamos que por aquí tenemos a nuestro
complejo citocromo v6
efe que es uno de los sectores de
electrones y tal vez en este complejo el
lugar que quiere aceptar a este electrón
se encuentra por acá y también digamos
que hay otro lugar en el complejo que
puede aceptar a un protón de hidrógeno y
digamos que ese lugar está por acá así
es que podemos imaginarnos fácilmente
que algún protón de hidrógeno llega y se
enlaza por acá pero
este punto de aquí se siente atraído por
el electrón con mucha energía y entonces
rota a todo este complejo que por cierto
tal vez este complejo es un poco más
esférico y entonces sintiendo la
atracción de este electrón gira la
molécula porque este electrón quiere
pasar a un estado con un nivel de
energía más bajo quiere sentirse más
cómodo entonces debido a esa atracción
esta molécula tal vez puede rotar y al
rotar este hidrógeno queda de este lado
y de esa forma cuando este punto y este
electrón se encuentren el hidrógeno ya
va a estar del otro lado y por aquí el
protón de hidrógeno ya se puede ir
flotando libremente bueno por lo menos
así es como yo me lo imagino
ok aquí tenemos un electrón que pasa a
un nivel de energía más bajo haciendo
que un protón de hidrógeno atraviese la
membrana y recuerda los electrones
realmente quieren hacer esto así es que
atraen a distintas partes de las
y las moléculas sintiendo esa atracción
pueden rotar y moverse y de esa forma se
facilita que los protones de hidrógeno
pasen del estroma al lumen que los
protones de hidrógeno pasen del exterior
del tnc y la coidh al interior del til
acoide y luego la alta concentración de
protones de hidrógeno de este lado es lo
que provoca la quimio smos ys que
termina produciendo moléculas de atp y
ahora aquí yo quiero que veamos otra
cosa y es el hecho de que por acá
empezamos con uno de los electrones de
una molécula de agua y cuando la
molécula de agua pierde sus dos protones
de hidrógeno y los electrones asociados
con esos protones nos queda simplemente
oxígeno molecular así es que por aquí
empezamos con una molécula de agua
y terminamos con oxígeno molecular y
protones de hidrógeno y el electrón
liberado en esta reacción se queda en la
clorofila ahora como ya hemos visto ese
electrón eventualmente termina en una
molécula dna bp h el aductor final de
esta cadena de transporte de electrones
es una molécula de n además que se
transforma en n
dp h podemos imaginarnos que toma algún
protón de hidrógeno que se encuentra
flotando por aquí junto con el electrón
de la cadena de transporte de electrones
y entonces se convierte en n adepe h y
flota libremente en el estroma que es
donde suceden las reacciones de la fase
oscura en las cuales se producen los
carbohidratos pero toda esta idea en la
que un electrón pasa de una molécula de
agua a una molécula dna de ph se llama
photo fosforilación a cíclica
y vamos a escribirlo por aquí auto
fosforilación a cíclica y se llama a
cíclica porque no estamos re utilizando
el mismo electrón una y otra vez el
electrón empieza depende de cómo lo veas
en una molécula de clorofila o de agua y
termina en una molécula de ndp h pero
ahora también hay otro tipo de foto
fosforilación y me imagino que ya sabes
cómo se llama
se llama photo fosforilación cíclica
cotto fosforilación cíclica y más
adelante cuando estamos estudiando el
ciclo de calvin o las reacciones de la
fase oscura también conocidas como las
reacciones independientes de la luz
vamos a ver que esas reacciones utilizan
un montón de atp aunque yo utilizan una
cantidad desproporcionada de atp con
respecto a la cantidad de enea de ph es
que utilizan utilizan un montón de ambas
moléculas pero utilizan muchísimos más
atp
y por acá este tipo de foto
fosforilación cíclica produce únicamente
atp y no oxida a ninguna molécula de
agua así es que lo que sucede en la foto
fosforilación cíclica es que este
electrón una vez que llega al
fotosistema uno en lugar de irse a una
molécula dna de ph se va a un
fotosistema 2 nuevamente así es que aquí
en el foto sistema 2 en lugar de obtener
un electrón a partir de una molécula de
agua utilizamos el mismo electrón que ya
teníamos por acá porque hoy digamos que
este electrón se pasa directamente a
algún fotosistema 2 aunque bueno si
queremos ser un poco más específicos
este electrón no necesariamente llega
hasta un foto sistema 2 puede ser que
llegue a alguna de estas otras moléculas
que se encuentran en una posición
posterior en la cadena de transporte de
electrones ok como laplace toki non ao
el citocromo b 6 f
pero el punto es que el electrón que se
encuentra en un estado excitado se
regresa a alguna de estas otras
moléculas y sigue bajando su nivel de
energía bombeando protones de hidrógeno
a través de la membrana hasta que
nuevamente llega a un fotosistema 1
donde vuelve a ser excitado a un nivel
mayor de energía y se repite nuevamente
el ciclo así es que como el electrón se
queda por aquí dando vueltas nunca llega
a una molécula de ndp más y por lo tanto
no se forman nuevas moléculas dna de ph
y entonces como seguimos teniendo a este
electrón en este ciclo no es necesario
quitarle sus electrones a las moléculas
de agua claro que entonces tampoco vamos
a estar produciendo oxígeno así es que
cuando nos encontramos con este tipo de
foto fosforilación la a cíclica que es
la que la mayoría de las personas asocia
con la foto fosforilación en esta
situación producimos moléculas de
oxígeno
dn a de p h y bueno por supuesto también
produce a t p mientras que la foto
fosforilación cíclica como no le tiene
que quitar sus electrones a moléculas de
agua no produce oxígeno y como los
electrones no terminan en una molécula
de ndp h tampoco producen en el ph por
lo que únicamente producen atp
únicamente producen atp ya que
entendemos bastante bien como suceden
estas reacciones de la fase luminosa en
la fotosíntesis ahora ya estamos listos
para tomar todos los productos de la
fase luminosa a ver recordemos cuáles
son los productos de la fase y luminosa
los tenemos por aquí el oxígeno ya no lo
necesitamos para la fotosíntesis
así es que podemos simplemente liberarlo
a la atmósfera para que otras personas y
otros animales lo puedan respirar y con
él hacer la respiración celular
en el contexto de la fotosíntesis aquí
hemos producido un montón de atp y
también un montón de línea de ph y
podemos utilizar a estos junto con
dióxido de carbono porque hay podemos
utilizar a estos junto con el dióxido de
carbono para formar carbohidratos y todo
esto sucede en el estroma no crea y todo
esto sucede por aquí en el estroma que
es el líquido que se encuentra adentro
del cloroplasto pero afuera del pti la
coidh que es todo este líquido por aquí
pero bueno vamos a hablar de eso en el
próximo vídeo